next question number five
exactly how much better are green berets
than the seals at what
i think we have to the first just like
me
at you know 21 years old i didn't
understand
the difference um so every
special mission unit has a pretty
well-defined mission
and all of them are different
i would never want to get in a gunfight
with a bunch of navy seals on a boat
anywhere near the water i mean within
like
miles of water it would be just a
catastrophe
um i also don't think that there's
anyone on the planet besides special
forces
that can do a force force multiplier
like we can you can take 12 of us
you can drop us in venezuela leave us
there for six months
and we probably overthrew the government
and place the president
the new president in place and running
the economics
the what the power plants the commerce
um transportation and like each of us
the 12 of us
uh have like married at least four or
five venezuelans
you know be like that's that's people
don't understand like why we have to
speak other languages
why we have to go through economic and
um
you know geopolitical classes it's
because we're different
like the missions are different what
we're supposed to do is different
um and
because of a different mission we end up
with different products and those
products are
groups of dudes that are the baddest
dudes the planet on the planet for what
they have to do
yeah and i mean i left that question in
there for a couple reasons number one
was because it was i thought it was kind
of funny you know obviously whoever
whoever wrote that had a sense of humor
and you know the real
question you know which is to me was
just about
really defining and i'd say the exact
same thing that you'd say
i would add this to it you know yes
you know you look at rangers you look at
seals you look at green beret you
you look at marshawk and everyone's got
their own little specialty of what
they're really good at and as a whole
they'll
they'll be better at that than the other
group and then within
the seals within the rangers within the
within sf
you got different levels of guys that
are in there yeah i know
you probably worked with some seals that
you thought one of these guys
and you probably work with some guys
that you said damn i'd love to love to
work with those guys
and the same thing with me i've worked
with some sf guys that i
thought to myself man these guys are
just these guys are unbelievable i would
do anything for these guys and sometimes
you look at them you go
i wonder how these guys made it through
yeah you get to teams i get to teams i'd
be like
did you really pass selection dude
that's one thing that's really hard for
the american public to understand
is that there is and i've explained this
a bunch of times on the podcast that
there's a bell curve just like any other
organization
there's the top guys that are you know
bad totally badass
you guys have just made it through and
then there's a bunch of guys in the
middle that are totally solid guys that
get it done all the time and then
there's a bunch of guys that just
they barely got through and they skate
and that's
you know that's part of the way it is
but one thing i can tell you for sure
is the special operations community
i don't limit my respect for the special
operations community alone
for me working with the army the the
conventional army guys the marine corps
marines i i they're always good oh
they're always good
they're they're consistently but you're
a rifle company dude
awesome yeah can i please work with you
because you just wanted like a bunch of
pit bulls they've been like locked up in
a cage and they just get prodded every
once while and
maybe they go and like tear something
apart and they get thrown like some raw
meat and they're like oh this is good
you know do i get what do i get to kill
to get another piece of this meat yeah
the marine corps really is
a an outstanding organization and then
there's units within the army
that are unbelievably just squared away
professional
and they have a heritage behind them of
glory for lack of a better word and so
i'm a huge fan of the entire military of
the entire us military
you know but like you are you proud to
be a seal
yeah i mean yeah you know yeah i'm proud
to be a green beret you know and i'm
like
when army plays navy like i don't know
crap about football
you know but i'm like go just for crying
out loud beat navy
you know for once in this
decade yeah or near century to be honest
with you i literally don't care
and the biggest when we were in ramadi
working with the army
and with the marine corps those guys the
sacrifices that they made were
so they were
so just impressive day-to-day what these
guys did
and you know we had of course we do have
better training
we do have better gear and yet those
marine corps
platoons and companies would be out
there doing
i mean they're first of all they're
living in the city you know we're going
back to a little
fob we got a little bit of video games
and huge walls
huge walls great gym yeah protein powder
exactly yeah those guys don't have any
of that they don't have any of that
we air dropped a pallet of porn and
protein to a firebase that pre a bunch
of marines that like saved our lives
when we were like knocking on their gate
at two o'clock in the morning we weren't
we were like 200 meters away and we
didn't want them all to murder us and
they were going to
yeah we're like please let us in um our
air won't come pick us up
and we got in there like you guys been
eating t-rats and they're like yeah yeah
we've been pretty much a gunfight every
single night you know like
yeah dude we're taking you guys carry
you guys
so god bless all of them no doubt about
that